hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is cameras never seen today I am
watching Saving Private Ryan for the
first time I assume is a film about a
guy named Private Ryan that they are
trying to see this is a film that's been
on Netflix for a while they actually
just took it off I actually I had to
rent it on DVD it's one that I've seen
I'm like that's the movie that I know I
have to watch at some point in my life
who was like voluntarily watch a really
sad long movie about war not me hi
camera hi camera so we're gonna watch
something I've got a couple options for
you
often one Saving Private Ryan the war
movie no no nah next option okay good
point option two parks and recreation
for the seventh time in a row that's the
one
okay difficult alright should we drink a
beer each we can each have one or we
could each have a couple beers that's
usually how that goes but I was recently
talking to Doug and the guys for the
last install to critic shoot and they
were saying that Saving Private Ryan
Citizen Kane which was nothing
I'll leave their own the fugitive those
are a couple of movies that I need to
watch and add to my list I'm a really
long list you guys but anyways today I
am watching Saving Private Ryan and I am
ready to watch a really good movie that
is going to be said so here we go oh wow
[Music]
damn that was so intense and crazy and
really hard to watch so I'm just gonna
read at my first page of notes just out
because I wasn't even writing sentences
I was just like oh god oh my god oh god
there's battle was nuts
horrible well done but just yeah oh my
god oh oh my god Jesus talked about
purposeful Gord holy hell
started the movie I was eating at
Chipotle burrito after battle Massacre
scene never eating again
oh my god it just keeps going I thought
it was done it wasn't done I've never
had such
hurt I'm watching a movie I just noticed
Vin Diesel's in this film also is that
Bryan Cranston credited some of the
actors that they have in this I didn't
realize it was them for a hot second
awesome really bad with faces and names
and people a big person now I really
enjoy spitting diesel in a lot of things
I thought you great in this for the
short time that evens the movie
Bryan Cranston isn't it for even a
shorter amount of time Tom Hanks is
always like an incredible delight for me
as a movie watcher so okay let's know
pretty wide a bit to be honest I have
seen the first just like couple minutes
of this movie cuz it was on Netflix and
I was like oh this is a movie I ever
talked about I'll watch the first bit of
it and I remember watching like five
minutes into the battle and just being
like oh this is just a lot of battles
whoa I'm sure it's over soon but not
into this Parks and Rec I had no idea
that the battle was so loved and it's so
in tense it was difficult for me to
watch I don't have a problem of gore
usually I rather my movies not have a
ton of gore like I love like this song
maybe used to like that but like I'll
watch them like I don't have a problem
watching them I just it just doesn't do
it for me like it doesn't scare me and
movies like this where it's so serves a
purpose it's way harder to watch I think
I've never had such a hard time watching
a bill before it's just intense right
isn't it so crazy ah so anyways then you
meet mrs. Ryan who has lost three out of
four of her children and the military is
like actually we're going to go get your
other child because you need that one
child god damn it so they create the
special task force to go find Private
Ryan
so Tom Hanks is the leader of this group
the commander not the words but he's the
leader the leader of the pack for Greece
then you've got all the name guys in
this group and it's an incredible group
of men
actors they are so good there's not a
weak link among them but all of those
guys think that it's a waste of time
they're not into this mission for the
most part then I peek then I heat it
then I posit to go pee yes I posit at 49
minutes in and I saw that the movie is 2
hours and 49 minutes I'm sorry what oh
my god long movies are long you know
what I mean is an extent just my left
cheek add up there then my only laugh of
the whole film comes from Paul Giamatti
who is talking about how his ankles are
weak like an old woman
just like girl I feel you yes Paul
Giamatti you're wonderful and everything
you're in by the way so another fun Club
I gotta wear my hair down like lenses I
know I saw the first scene I know I was
there for that but I wasn't expecting
almost all of the team to die I also
wasn't expecting two people to live who
live for them to live I think I was
expecting different people maybe Vin
Diesel first president died I really was
enjoying him in the movie which is a
good thing I guess like they're like
yeah you're comfortable BAM I said this
isn't what I was expecting
honestly this is real it's just a
devastating war movie simple as you can
get their camera but honestly it's true
so in the group of guys under Tom Hanks
command they've got the language guide
it's a little scrawny dude who can speak
French and German and so that's why they
need him with them up in opinions I
think Upton Upton is his character me
and he asked Tom Hanks who where he's
from and Tom is like what's uh what's
the been at now that was so good I
really liked that aspect this was the
movie where he's like I know I know
I know they're betting on where I'm from
he's like um biggest 300 sir he's like
well when it gets to 500 I'll tell you
about the money he's like I feel
compelled to advise you to wait until a
thousand sir
after and he's like we probably won't be
alive till then so let's do 500 as soon
as they like great sweetie
it was a nice moment Adam Goldberg
that's what I'm looking for what else
has he been in Oh laughing Wow a monster
in Paris
oh he's didn't bathe the piggy city rate
he was in the end and the coal story he
was in homeward bound too good for him
but I love that he is a Jewish soldier
and they're fighting against the Germans
and they take Germans captive and he's
showing them his Star of David he's like
yeah see that big his big head I wrote
all of the acting is great but the medic
is X being sectional oh and then he died
this is hog so he gets shot by the enemy
obviously and since he's the medic
they're like tell us what to do they're
like here's here's where you hurt me but
pushing on his stomach and he's like oh
well fuck it's my liver damn they're
like what can we do and he's like well I
would like some more morphine please
because nothing you can't there's
nothing to do so then they capture one
of the German soldiers that was shooting
at them up in the Linguistics guy is
like linguistics is that what the word
Zoey for language linguistics right Wow
guy who speaks things it's like they all
want to shoot him because he he just
shot their best friend and so obviously
he's like but actually he's a prisoner
of war you can't shoot in this against
the rule times it's like yeah you're
right so he let him go and they're all -
they're like rules because he just shot
one of our best friends and we're on
this mission and everything is so ha ha
ha ha sorry Walter I know you got that
the next thing I wrote is this is just a
really long really sad movie Tom Hanks
you better not die seriously
Oh past camera use simple a naive fool
and then my DVD skips which is annoying
yes but seemingly insignificant while
watching this film so to break the
tension Tom Hanks finally reveals where
he's from everyone's yelling everyone's
yelling and he goes hey what's the pole
rack guys he's like I'm a school teacher
it was a great moment god I'm so glad he
was a school teacher what a cool thing
of course he's so great and patient and
wonderful so then they actually find
Ryan they find Matt Damon and so of
course he refuses to go he takes a
moment to be super sad about his
brothers and then he's like but why
would I go when all of these men has
fought as hard as me why would I go no
get away bitch
hey Zack hands Tom Hanks and then he
runs around with Tanza whoa so they side
with Ryan's very small squadron who have
been just picked apart so they decide to
stay there so that they can get Ryan out
after they won this next battle so then
the bad guys come with like four tanks
and like 60 men another really long
battle scene and it was so good and well
done then I wrote Oh everyone dies so
Tom Max and then the language guy in
linguistics guy are alive oh also the
Apple guy and the second in command guy
Mike JK Mike is dead
then you see the guy that they had let
go they didn't kill I wanted to so rapid
they let him go he is now shooting it
then and she shoots Tom hey no no not
Tom not my friends Tom no no no no no oh
no no no no so finally some hell comes
in the form of a airplane Thank You
America I know the resources were
limited just it's just good good
then up and shoots the guy that they let
go and shoot something he shoots him
this is the first kill that he has in
the whole movie and it's just really
good satisfying a moment so the u.s.
takes control and Tom Hanks dies after
telling Matt Damon like earned this
deserve it early and then it cuts back
to the scene you see in the very
beginning where it's old Matt it's sad
it's the sad movies the good movie is
sad and it was stressful but good good
doesn't mean happy it means good war
isn't good but good men go to war this
is a good movie if there's so many good
things that have come from the series
and all systems bullshit but like mostly
good for like the best thing that's come
from this is just I've just gotten an
excuse to like I have to watch movies
that I should have watched in my
lifetime it's like really cool to see
these movies anyways guys thanks for
watching I felt when she ate you guys
watching this and leaving nice kind
comments and then everyone else can just
go jump off a cliff can't put that in
there nice though
maybe I will put it anyways I put up a
video on my personal channel yesterday
and it has Rachel Pink's in it and she's
wonderful we answered some movie trivia
that you guys sent me on Twitter and we
did really well as expected
oh no there's no cats in this episode
sorry guys next week
night just look out for Ike next week
what a stars I got it
[Music]